[Música]
el presidente electo de ecuador
guillermo lasso se comprometió a hacer
de la lucha contra la corrupción una de
las prioridades de su gobierno prometió
además vacunar contra el coi 19 a 9
millones de personas durante los
primeros 100 días de su mandato y
aseguró que eliminará el déficit fiscal
del país andino en 4 años
el secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg pidió a rusia que retire sus
tropas de la zona de frontera con
ucrania el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de ucrania dmitro culeba
pidió más sanciones contra moscú
mientras que desde el kremlin señalan a
eeuu y a la alianza trasatlántica de
convertir a ucrania en un polvorín
y la muerte de otro ciudadano
afroamericano a manos de las autoridades
en mineápolis desató una nueva jornada
de protestas el policía habría
supuestamente sacado su pistola por
error
habiendo querido alcanzar su tercer los
hechos se producen en una ciudad ya
tensa por el avance del juicio contra el
ex policía de dexia bin acusado del
homicidio en el caso del shorts flores
bienvenidos a una nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y el mundo
aquí en france 24 mi nombre es liliana
valencia comenzamos de esta misión en
ecuador' guillermo lasso presidente
electo del país hizo un llamado a que
haya un gobierno de unidad y aseguró que
no perseguirá judicialmente a ninguna
fuerza opositora el conservador defendió
su meta de vacunar a 9 millones de
ecuatorianos en los primeros 100 días de
su administración y aseguró que luchará
contra la corrupción para paliar la
crisis económica que vive la nación no
perseguiremos absolutamente a nadie
unidad para superar las crisis económica
y sanitaria que vive ecuador ese fue el
llamado del virtual presidente electo
guillermo lasso yo tengo los brazos
abiertos como lo he dicho y a nadie debe
sorprenderle que
en mi gabinete
se incluye a personas de otras tiendas
políticas inclusive aquellos que no
concordaron con nuestro proyecto
inicialmente
el ecuador pasa por un momento crucial
difícil la diversidad en el gabinete
ayudará al proceso de gobernabilidad la
virtual victoria de lazo se produce pese
a que en primera vuelta el candidato de
la izquierda y heredero de rafael correa
andrés arauz ganó por 13 puntos
porcentuales y luego de que el entonces
candidato indígena ya q pérez denunciara
un supuesto fraude sin embargo el lazo
aseguró que durante su gobierno la
justicia no se encargará de perseguir a
la oposición que se comprometió a luchar
contra la corrupción y la evasión de
impuestos asimismo dejó en manos de la
justicia los procesos contra el ex
mandatario ecuatoriano plazo defendió su
meta de vacunar a 9 millones de personas
en los primeros 100 días de su
administración y resaltó las
dificultades que el país vive a causa de
la pandemia de kobe 19 que actualmente
deja más de 17.000 fallecidos la
prioridad de hoy y no solamente en el
campo de salud sanidad social
si no en el campo económico es vacunar a
los ecuatorianos necesitamos que pierdan
el miedo que salgan a las calles con
seguridad y tranquilidad y así poder
reactivar la economía
esteban quiero conservador recibe el
poder cuando el 14 9% de la población
vive en la pobreza extrema y cuando el
país debe pagar 7 mil 400 millones de
dólares al fondo monetario internacional
y a otros organismos por lo que debe
encontrar la forma de reestructurar las
cuentas estatales tras sostener una
reunión con el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de ucrania de un nitro culeba
en bruselas para hablar de la crisis en
la región del donbass el secretario
general de la otan jens stoltenberg
pidió nada pidió a rusia que retire las
tropas de la zona limítrofe stoltenber
denunció la mayor aglomeración de tropas
rusas en la frontera desde la anexión de
crimea en 2014 que tachó nuevamente de
ilegal pidió a rusia poner fin a lo que
calificó como una provocación el
ministro de exteriores ucraniano abogó
por mayores sanciones contra moscú y
apoyo para fortalecer las capacidades de
defensa de kiev
la acumulación de tropas por parte de
rusia es injustificado en explicado y
profundamente preocupante rusia debe
poner fin a esa expansión militar en la
frontera con ucrania detener las
provocaciones y es escalar la situación
inmediatamente indiferente mientras en
bruselas también se encuentra el
secretario de estado estadounidense
anthony blinken el ministro relaciones
exteriores de rusia serguéi lávrov llegó
a teherán allí se reunió con el
presidente iraní hassan rohani y
previamente con el ministro de
relaciones exteriores mohamad yavad
sharif el canciller iraní calificó como
una muy mala puesta el supuesto ataque a
la instalación nuclear de natanz dl que
culpa a israel
sharif aseguró que lo ocurrido
fortalecería la posición de teherán de
cara a una nueva ronda de diálogos en
viena que busca reactivar el acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 en el que eeuu se retiró
en 2018
y vuelve las protestas a la ciudad
estadounidense de mineápolis y su vecina
brooklyn centre es donde murió un joven
afroamericano tras recibir un disparo de
la policía supuestamente por error
durante un control de tránsito minnesota
ya se encuentra en una tensa situación
por el juicio contra el ex agente
derecha bin acusado de matar al
afroamericano georg floyd hace casi un
año veamos el informe
centenares de manifestantes en las
calles de mineápolis y municipios
aledaños de nuevo
igual que hace casi un año se incendió
la ciudad por la muerte del
afroamericano georges floyd esta vez las
protestas denuncian la muerte de donde
wright un joven negro de 20 años que
murió por los disparos de un agente
blanca de policía la del lunes fue la
segunda noche de virulentas protestas a
pesar de que las autoridades han
decretado un toque de queda y de qué
mineápolis se encuentra bajo extremas
medidas de seguridad precisamente por el
juicio contra derecho ven el policía que
ahogó a georges floyd el presidente de
eeuu llamó a la calma
tenemos que esperar una investigación
completa
mientras tanto lo dejo claro no hay
ninguna justificación para los saqueos
ni la violencia
la policía de brooklyn center la ciudad
donde murió el joven raid hizo públicas
las imágenes del incidente
justo después la policía le apunta y le
dispara las autoridades indican de
manera preliminar que la gente confundió
su pistola taser con la de verdad las
imágenes de escalofriantes han encendido
todavía más los ánimos
ahora el mundo observa el juicio con la
policía de brooklyn center
para mostrar lo mortífera que es la
policía contra la gente de color mató a
un joven desarmado de 20 años
precisamente un nuevo testimonio volvió
a ratificar ante los tribunales que
floyd murió por asfixia en un juicio que
se vive como un veredicto sobre el
racismo en la sociedad estadounidense
y hay polémica en japón las autoridades
aprobaron la liberación de más de un
millón de toneladas de agua contaminada
de la planta nuclear de fukushima
devastada por un terremoto y posterior
tsunami en 2011 al océano pacifico
aunque el gobierno asegura que el agua
será tratada para reducir los niveles de
radiación el hecho ya genera protestas
tanto de activistas como de
representantes de la industria pesquera
veamos el informe
no pongan en peligro el futuro de
nuestros hijos activistas antinucleares
se manifestaron frente al parlamento
japonés rechazan el plan del gobierno de
verter el agua contaminada de la central
nuclear de fukushima al océano pacífico
diez años después del tsunami que
provocó el desastre las reacciones en
cadenas siguen afectando a los reactores
dañados y el complejo casi no tiene
espacio para almacenar el agua de
refrigeración que se acumula a un ritmo
de 170 toneladas diarias el agua
contaminada se filtra primero antes de
ser almacenada pero el dispositivo no
tiene la capacidad de eliminar el trillo
un isótopo radiactivo del hidrógeno
a nivel de tritio por debajo de los
límites impuestos por las autoridades
japonesas y también por la o ms en
cuanto a las normas de seguridad del
agua potable los científicos consideran
que niveles bajos de trillo no son
peligrosos para el medio ambiente pero
los pescadores japoneses están
preocupados
antes de cierto
y hemos dicho repetidamente al gobierno
que nos oponemos categóricamente a este
plan de muestra de texto los habitantes
temen en efecto las repercusiones del
vertido sobre la calidad de la industria
pesquera un sector esencial en una
región ya castigada y aunque el proceso
no es nuevo las aguas residuales que
contienen tritio se vierten regularmente
en los océanos china y corea del sur
también se muestran preocupadas por la
decisión de tokio más de un millón de
toneladas de agua de refrigeración están
almacenadas actualmente en el sitio de
fukushima su liberación en el océano
podría comenzar dentro de dos años
continúen con más tempranas 24 punto com
[Música]